my dear okay this is step does his
stepdaughter is a step to this step we
are all steps oh my gosh my mic just
fell out of my underpants there you go
oh I can do stand hold it together okay
there you go
oh she's walking what we've got on the
back of the cat business yeah no no okay
it's got it and walk around here yep yep
okay and I'll just pop you here at the
end
okay Beauty I'm next you is Kurt Russell
hi Kurt
how are you see we met briefly at SNL 40
I saw you the other male the other male
voices at all I'm Josh you found it
funny I caught a little bit of you on
the way in do you want to drink oh thank
you there you go
okay no it is a non-alcoholic beverage
isn't it I don't know it's not piss it's
a fine we all we all went in it while
you were singing and what we call a free
lap that's this really get a good look
at this yeah it's water you're you're
really great and you're obviously quite
brilliant thank you yeah if you keep
this going for about ten years and just
live your life wouldn't it be cool if
that worked
yeah nobody knows mhmmm else feel like a
spare part but it was a current last
time see it was here it was her back was
to the camera yeah so baby steps you're
now facing in the right direction yeah
yeah because the track the fact we just
heard alive that's on the new album
which called this is acting thank you
for talking about it now is that that's
not you though in prosthetics it's not
prosthetics that's some digital work and
some sticky tape
I took my shoulders out and I made my
neck longer and I changed the shape of
my eyes and sticky tape my nose okay
what a lovely Christmas card it's turned
into that value that arm is not on till
29th of January but yeah I know yeah I'm
here I'm slogging away early
yeah no do it do it sell it for your
Christmas and and now are you bored of
asking but if it is interesting because
25 just came out blah blah blah that you
did co-write this this song with Adele
yes yeah yeah
you've written this all mini artists
saying and they're big anthems all of
them so can you ever tour an album yeah
you just do it you do it down actually
Adele gave me a top tip she was like
yeah whenever you can't hit the high
note you just like you're like lalala
I was like there's a reason she has
eighty million dollars the rest and
Counting
starter and yeah for sure I don't I
probably didn't see a penis until I was
least 20 and that was probably a medical
journal so I love you I know